a centuries-old Quran from Central Asia
still in pristine condition
700 volumes of quranic manuscripts from
China and Southeast Asia make the
collection at qatar's National Library
one of the largest of its kind
behind the books the headquarters of a
project to track stolen artifacts so
himaya we launched that project in 2020
with
Interpol and the world custom
organization and the International
Federation of libraries to insist on the
fact that manuscripts are also suffering
from trafficking and it's it is a
disaster so everybody speaks always
about archeology but we forget the
manuscripts Stefan and his colleagues
recently discovered people allegedly
linked to the former government who were
trying to sell an ancient Koran for more
than one million dollars I immediately
contacted the Interpol and asked to to
act so it was not so easy because
actually the theft was never declared to
the police in Kabul so officially they
could not have action then it's more
complicated because the restitution is
more difficult because of the political
situation in Afghanistan and it's not a
isolated case
this year we finally between 5 and 10
manuscripts on sale in various countries
members of the Taliban guard
Afghanistan's National Museum these days
protecting what's left of the
collections some historical sites have
withstood years of different powers
fighting for control of Afghanistan
the Dhaka Zafar or arch of victory in
Pacman is more than 100 years old after
years of wars and conflict much of
Afghanistan's historic Heritage has been
destroyed unlike last time they were in
power the Taliban said they will protect
and preserve what belongs to all afghans
a stark contrast to the group's
destruction of Buddhist Heritage when it
came to power in the 1990s
we are protecting the National Archive
Museum Gallery library and other
important places the historical
artifacts of Afghanistan should be
preserved Customs agents were stationed
at the airport and they managed to
intercept a lot of artifacts that were
being smuggled and they were taken to
the museum but returning stolen
Antiquities isn't that simple
Western countries don't have diplomatic
Coalition with Afghanistan today so they
don't want to restitute something and
they don't recognize the the current
government so they they use that as an
excuse
very often also it's difficult to find
the legitimate owner in the case I'm
mentioning for Afghanistan we have all
the evidences so at least we know where
it should be restituted and until the
Taliban and international organizations
work together more Afghan Heritage is
likely to disappear or go under the
hammer Kabul